see how I'm adding right the next one is
if you subtract subtract so if you take
one and then you subtract right here's
one the great things about understanding
functions and investors right see here
excuse me how adding turns it to
multiplication right
adding logs turns into multiplication of
these things inside right well adding
and subtracting are a function and its
inverse
do you see that right add subtract add
subtract so therefore if I've got the
universe here and here then actually
expect the inverse here on the right
hand side as well this is multiplication
what's the inverse what's the reverse of
modification answer divide write
division so you've got over here not XY
but X divided by one okay again I can
prove it enormous identical way to this
but instead of this step I'm going to
divide I'm going to do X over Y and I'm
gonna see what happens to the in there
indices okay all right that's number two
number three if you add this over and
over again right forever again if I go
log a X plus log a X plus log a X right
so for example 5 2 3 of them right
adding laws turns into multiplication so
what do you expect this to become you go
x times x time it's right did you read
that so that's going to be X cubed okay
now this is just one version of it right
if I add it four times I'll get X to the
4 if I added a 50 times I've had an X to
the 50 okay so just state that more
generally if I add it n times n times
right that's me adding and logs all
together in a heap right well that's the
same as multiplying this guy n times you
see adding it turns into multiplication
right and just compressing that is more
so this is our power wall that we use
here okay all right really quickly just
to generally say these guys right if you
take any log sorry any base any machine
right any um any grid great you like
right how long will it take that machine
to get something to its original size
it's uh no time at all doesn't matter
how fast or slow it grows right because
you're just talking about the original
size right you can say here we go
Bogg they say hey what's that gonna mean
it means you've got a growing machine it
grows at a rate of a its its way of
finding the object every minute right
well how long will it take to get a
touch bigger answer just that one minute
one minute another way of looking at it
is look at it from the other side right
remember every exponential and every log
form
I just reverse of each other just turn
the coin around so if I rewrite this
it's a to the power of 1 equals a more
positives right like that's the most
it's not even a log law it's not even in
this level it's just kind of obvious
okay alright one more
taking this back here okay if you've got
the fraction in there right you're not
growing anymore are you you're getting
smaller okay so if you've got a growing
machine and it's mixing things go
smaller then where are you going in time
you're in backwards in time right so
this is negative one okay I can restate
it another way I can rewrite using index
laws right I can rewrite one array in
index form how do I do that it's at a
power of negative 1 right that's like
this but with a instead of 2 okay so
that's equal to well that minus 1 using
this one here should come out the front
you see that the power can jump out the
front minus one but like two minutes ago
you told me what more base a of a is
it's
one right so you've got the - I'm
hanging up the phone does that make
sense
so you see this is a lot about
memorizing there Wars
okay it's about asking the right
question it's about asking that time and
how long something is growing and
everything else just falls out from
there